ja es regt mich eigentlich gar nicht so
stark auf es besorgt mich eigentlich
mehr dass wir in einem land leben in dem
der mangel mehr oder weniger zum alltag
geworden ist zum einen was das thema
straßenbrücken angeht der
verkehrsminister hat angekündigt dass er
bis zu 400 brücken pro jahr sanieren
möchte einfach weil sie so marode sind
wir sehen also zum einen es gibt mangel
in den schulen auf den straßen bei den
brücken aber es gibt auch mangel beim
personal und das erkennen wir in diesen
tagen immer deutlich haben vor allem mit
blick auf den sommerurlaub in nordrhein
westfalen stehen die großen sommerferien
an ist droht ein riesiges flugchaos am
kommenden wochenende am flughafen an den
flughäfen in nordrhein-westfalen warum
weil das bodenpersonal fehlt weil es
nicht genug ab fertiger in den flughäfen
gibt tausende flüge sind abgesagt worden
für diesen sommer warum weil es nicht
genug mitarbeiter gibt piloten
flugbegleiter die fehlen
schwimmbäder und frei wieder machen
früher zu und sperren morgens später auf
warum weiß nicht mehr genug bademeister
und personal gibt wir sehen das auch in
restaurants und kneipen ganz häufig
heißt es um 21 oder um 22 uhr wir machen
dicht und wir sind noch gar nicht am
ende dieser entwicklung wir sind am
anfang zur zeit gibt es rund 1,7
millionen offene stellen in deutschland
1,7 millionen aber es gibt bereits
untersuchungen die sagen bis 2030 20 31
gibt es fünf millionen beschäftigte zu
wenig bei uns das heißt das was wir
jetzt erleben den mangel der sich so
langsam in dieses land rein frisst der
wird noch viel viel größer viel viel
stärker dass das was mich besorgt das
heißt auch die politik muss umdenken sie
muss um steuern sie muss alles dafür tun
nicht nur dass menschen in beschäftigung
kommen aber auch dass menschen nicht
jobs machen die sinnlos sind weil sie
sich um bürokratie kümmern weil sie hier
irgendwelche akten lesen müssen die
eigentlich unnötig sind die also
arbeitskraft binden die woanders viel
viel produktiver eingesetzt werden wird
also deutschland darf nicht zu einem
land werden wo es heißt geht nicht
gibt's doch sondern es muss weiter
gelten geht nicht das gibt es auch nicht
jan in deiner position als politikchef
welches zeugnis für das tue denn gerade
der politik dafür verleihen wie sie der
mangelwirtschaft umgeht wie aktiv
dagegen man muss natürlich jetzt sehen
die ampel regierung die bundesregierung
ist erst seit einem halben jahr im amt
und ist da sozusagen rhein geworfen
worden aber wir haben eine
bundesregierung davor eine große
koalition die am stück acht jahre
regiert hat und hier das thema natürlich
verschlafen insgesamt stellen wir auch
fest wir haben es irgendwie alle auch
über letzten zwei jahre gar nicht so
mitbekommen weil wir natürlich die lok
downs hatten die korona zeit zwei sommer
lang in denen auch viele hotels gar
nicht richtig geöffnet hatten in dem
viele leute oder in den sommern in denen
viele leute zu hause geblieben sind weil
sie gesagt haben ich bleibe mal lieber
hier wer weiß ob ich überhaupt nach
österreich oder nach spanien komme da
ist das ganze nicht so aufgefallen aber
jetzt ist das wie bei einer ketchup
flasche am anfang tröpfelt nur und diese
noch mal merken wir es kommt richtig
einen flaschen raus auf den teller und
wir stellen fest die mangelwirtschaft
die erfasst uns wie gesagt nicht nur
beim thema infrastruktur sondern jetzt
auch beim thema beim thema personal das
bricht an allen ecken und enden raus und
es ist ja nicht nur die sozusagen die
sommer wirtschaft es ist der paketfahrer
der fehlt ist das pflegepersonal das
fehlt obwohl wir immer mehr pfleger
haben wir haben nicht weniger aber immer
mehr gibt es auch da immer noch zu wenig
wir sehen es bei fachkräften langes
thema also eigentlich die gesamte
bandbreite an jobs in deutschland
ist betroffen es gibt viel mehr
nachfrage extrem viel nachfrage aber zu
wenig arbeitskräfte angebot nun ist ja
ein schäfer ja eigentlich ein großer
verfechter des marktes mich also mag
muss es regeln markt soll es regeln
politik soll die nicht rein wo sich
entspannt was ihr kommt frage ich mich
wie wie erklärst du dir denn jetzt uns
dahin sein weil das die politik jetzt
unbedingt handeln muss was der markt
normalerweise regelt aber
gedanken dazu wir haben und da stimme
ich dir völlig zu das gefühl dass nichts
mehr funktioniert in deutschland egal ob
du mit der bahn fährt oder ob du mit dem
auto fährt oder mit dem flugzeug wärs
und die frage ist halt insofern bin ich
auch ein bisschen beide in diesem punkt
wer regelt das eigentlich und das gefühl
ist da es ist keiner da das regelt weil
es allen egal im endeffekt und das darf
natürlich nicht sein aber nochmal zurück
der macht der worte übrig auch so
vollkommen recht wenn der markt es
regeln sollte beim thema rente
beispielsweise und klassischer fall
dem versucht wird der markt bei der
rente regel sowieso nicht viel aber wo
man sagen könnte wenn die menschen immer
älter werden dann müssten sie eigentlich
auch später in die rente gehen das zum
beispiel verhindern die sozialdemokraten
vehement die cdu hat mit verhindert die
ampel fährt auch und dafür die rente
jetzt mit den flugzeugen und mit den
bahnen zog die hat mit dem
personalmangel extrem viel zu tun denn
wir kommen in eine phase in der
stichwort baby boomer immer mehr
menschen in rente gehen aber immer
weniger junge leute in den arbeitsmarkt
hineinwachsen deswegen kommen wir zu
einer lücke die zur zeit bei rund
450.000 licht zu einer lücke von
ungefähr fünf millionen im jahr 20 31 es
regelt es denn der markt und natürlich
der planwirtschaft sei alles andere aus
dem planwirtschaftlich auch für den
markt ja natürlich bin ich für den markt
aber der markt muss auch die richtigen
impulse setzen ich fühle mich da jetzt
ein bisschen gekitzelt was sie sagen als
als außerparlamentarische
bildungspolitiker ja wir haben die
situation in den letzten 15 jahren dass
wir mehr studenten studierende muss man
heute sagen mehr studenten haben
studienanfänger als leute die eine
berufliche bildung anfangen und da haben
wir ja auch den mangel ja wir haben das
muss ich jetzt mit einer gewissen
provokanten absicht sagen wir haben zu
viele junge leute die relativ
überflüssige fächer studieren
irgendwas mit medien und die sollten
jetzt lieber kenner werden
immer wieder bemerkt es ist vor 20 30
jahren den jungen leuten weisgemacht
worden der mensch beginnt beim abitur
vor ein paar jahren hieß es dann der
mensch beginnt mit hochschulabschluss
wie bachelor in den beruf der
schauspielerin herr kraus wenn wir über
berufe rinn ist sehr wichtig genug der
frau wulff den weiter ausüben oder
sollte sie jetzt auch lieber schnell den
personalmangel der den deckel drauf
setzt auch mithelfen ich will ja nicht
um schwul ist eine ernst gemeinte frage
um zu verstehen was sie meinen mit
berufen die nicht wichtig sind oder
nicht man die nicht braucht das
dienstleistungen sind ausgedünnten und
wir kriegen die auch nicht
bis jetzt diese positionen durch
zuwanderung das gilt ja immer als es das
große patent rezept grunde könnte man
vielleicht jetzt
über den vorschlag der nicht erst von
steinmeier kaum nachdenken
pflichtdienst jahres was das problem ein
bisschen größer ist schon wieder
gestorben was ist also das problem lösen
also dass der klempner jetzt ist mache
ich einen pflicht gleich ein halbes jahr
in einem auto zu bleiben habe aber ein
werk aus der regel ja du bist ja auch
selber das aber dem aussetzen der
wehrpflicht ja dann ein riesen loch
entstanden ist in den garten pflegen und
stein kommt aber nicht durch die
aussetzung der wehrpflicht der sehr
freuen aber ich hätte dann halt unter
denen die nicht zur bundeswehr gehen
wollen und die also den ersatzdienst
machen hätte ich ein jahr lang leute die
dort zumindest
hilft jährlich können und motivierte
menschen sollen sich um
den schwiegervater die mutter kümmern
hat das möchte ich ehrlich gesagt haben
sie da möchte ich keine andere lösung
klar ich denke dass pädagogisch ich
denke da pädagogisch
es kann doch von einem jungen menschen
der eine lebensphase lang
79 jahre bei männlichen neugeborenen ist
die lebenserwartung wird auch sich bei
weiblichen neugeborenen wird
wahrscheinlich sich noch steigern der
sein leben lang von der infrastruktur
dieses land sie hat erst 12 jahre
gelitten hat während der korona trier
nicht seine träume leben konnte ja
verlangen dass der ein jahr dieses immer
längeren lebens in das gemeinwesen das
im spiel bietet investiert ohne jetzt
darüber zu debattieren ob es das also ob
es jetzt richtig ist oder nicht ich bin
dagegen aber er würde es das denn lösen
also glauben sie wenn wir das jetzt
schon sagen dass ja dann sind wir durch
das ist eine maßnahme ist eine maßnahme
ja und dann bin ich schon auch
marktwirtschaftler dann muss halt der
markt wo besteht der klempner ist oder
irgendein anderer dienstleister ist muss
halt so attraktive angebote haben dass
der sagt okay da
krieg ich das gleiche wie wenn ich was
man sich irgendwann medien müssen
wissenschaftler machen und was brauchen
die medien wir sind eher bemerken wir
brauchen auch eine kultur der
verantwortlichkeit wenn ich jeden tag
lese dass in den flughäfen aus in
münchen witzigerweise in deutschland das
personal fehlt wohin sich koffer türmen
in den abflug zahlen die nirgendwohin
mehr zugestellt werden da muss doch
irgendjemand sagen der verantwortlich
ist okay das ist unser flughafen das ist
der flughafen der landesregierung wo die
das land vielleicht beteiligt ist das
ist wohl wo dieses landesregierung sitzt
wir fühlen uns dafür zuständig wenn eine
baustelle fünf jahre lang eine baustelle
ist muss doch jemand sagen wer
zuständige bauminister freunde geht das
nicht schneller wenn ähnliche beispiele
da sind die sogenannten hass in den
zügen war ich heute habe ich eine
reklame gesehen für den biss bordbistro
her kann ich wirklich nur lachen bei
jedem bordbistro ich verfilzung dass ich
da hinter vielen entwickeln speisen
fehlt das personal oder die
klimatisierung ist ausgefallen sind dass
das ding sowieso geschlossen ist also es
muss doch jemand verantwortung
übernehmen für diese missstände und
sagen wir wollen das ändern und das
vermisse ich und das muss sein weil es
hat sich auch so eine art ikone
eingependelt das wirklich sehe ich auf
der bahn auch so geht es für späte gucke
ich halt noch ein bisschen netflix auch
egal das darf nicht sein und niemand
regt sich mehr auf außer alte männer
vielleicht die über diese missstände und
das ist etwas was gibt die kultur und
realisierung des herrn das ja eigentlich
mal an sich arbeitet die zerbröselt
dadurch die kultur des landes und alles
was damit zu tun hat weil politik auch
immer nur fünf jahre voraus ich glaube
der punkt aber die neue macht hat er ist
ein ganz wichtiger dass sie gesagt haben
dass es eine zeit lang ja in der politik
eigentlich üblich war zu sagen wenn du
nicht abitur gemacht hast bist du
eigentlich kein wertvoller oder
gleichwertiger mensch und das ist das
was das handwerk beispielsweise auch
beklagt und wenn man sich überlegt dass
man heutzutage im durchschnitt auf einen
handwerker egal welche dienstleistung im
durchschnitt neun wochen warten muss
wenn man einen elektriker braucht wir
haben die erfahrung der selbst in berlin
gemacht zum teil drei monate warten muss
weil die bücher einfach sofort und dass
er sagt ja in drei monaten könnte wieder
anrufen vielleicht haben sie glück
vielleicht auch pech dann ist das dann
schreit das ja geradezu danach zu sagen
leute geht ins handwerk macht etwas und
werdet richtig richtig reich mit ganz
toller ehrlicher arbeit und jan warum
das vielleicht nicht klappt da haben
doch ihre these
komme ich gerne da hat auch aber die
wirtschaft versagt weil auch die
wirtschaft jahrelang den abiturienten
dem realschüler vorgezogen hat und den
realschüler den hauptschüler vorgezogen
hat und da hat sich in den köpfen der
eltern natürlich festgesetzt aber okay